من الواضح أن أجندة السياحة لدينا تتمثل في زيادة عدد الوافدين الذين لدينا حاليًا في عام 2019 ، حيث كانت البلاد تستوعب حوالي 1.2 مليون وافد دولي ولكن من الواضح مع جائحة كوبي 19 ، انخفضت الأرقام بشكل كبير وهو ما كان من الواضح أنه كان ضربة لقطاعنا نحن نريد أن يكون لدينا أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص للمجيء والاستمتاع بالموارد الطبيعية التي لدينا في زامبيا من الموارد الطبيعية التي لدينا في زامبيا اليوم ، نتحدث عن واحدة من الحياة البرية لدينا في زامبيا تضم 20 متنزهًا وطنيًا أكبرها حديقة الكفير الوطنية ، أعني أنها موطن لأكثر من 3000 موطن للحيوانات ، تفتخر زامبيا بأنها موطن قوة فيكتوريا العظيمة واحدة من عجائب الدنيا السبع الطبيعية ، لذلك مع هذين الجانبين الخاصين اللذين ذكرتهما ، هذا ما نريده شجع سياحنا على القدوم والمشاهدة وأيضًا المجيء والشعور باندفاع الأدرينالين الموجود داخل زامبيا واندفاع الأدرينالين الذي نتحدث عنه  نوبة
هي الأنشطة الموجودة داخل
فكتوريا فورس
المياه البيضاء التي تجديف القفز بالحبال
والسباحة تحت الرذاذ
وكل تلك الأشياء الفاخرة التي تريد
أن
تكون قد أدركناها لفترة طويلة جدًا
الآن الأرقام التي كانت
تأتي إلى زامبيا من  الشرق الأوسط
صغير جدًا وهذا أحد الأسباب
التي دفعتنا إلى حضور المعرض حيث
نشارك في المعرض بدلاً من
[موسيقى]
نتحدث بالفعل عن
المرافق الموجودة في زامبيا
من حيث الإقامة هي  إنهم يتحدثون
إلى السوق بأننا نستهدف
الأنشطة ، وأدرك أن 70 من
السكان خاصة في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
تقل أعمارهم عن 30 عامًا ، لذلك الآن هؤلاء هم من الفتيان والفتيات الصغار
الذين لديهم فضول شديد
ويريدون رؤيتهم يريدون المغامرة لذلك نحن بحاجة
للبدء في التحدث إلى
إنشاء مرافق تتحدث إليهم
، ثم نتطلع أيضًا إلى
تناول الطعام ، لذا فإننا نتطلع إلى
إنشاء
مطاعم معينة تسمح للمطاعم
التي ستتحدث بالفعل إلى  السوق الذي نستهدفه جائحة kovi 19 الذي دمر قطاع السياحة في جميع أنحاء زامبيا لم يكن استثناءً وإذا كنت ستتحدث عن زامبيا فنحن نتحدث عن أه يخسر أكثر من 300 مليون دولار كل عام في السياحة نحن نتحدث عن الاضطرار إلى خسارة أكثر من 65000 وظيفة مباشرة وغير مباشرة بسبب الطمع ، لذا فإن أول شيء فعلناه هو البحث في المنزل ، حيث تحدثنا في الواقع عن خلق فرصة للزامبيين لزيارة زامبيا. كان ذلك أنه لا يوجد شخص أفضل للإعلان عن زامبيا من الزامبيين أنفسهم الآن الشيء الثاني الواضح أن ما فعلناه هو التأكد من أن زامبيا هي وجهة ذاتية للأمة الإنتانية من حيث الأمن والوجهة الذاتية من حيث الصحة ، لقد أصررنا على أن السياحة يقود القطاع حملة التطعيم المرغوبة ، لذا في الوقت الحالي في قطاع السياحة ، نتمتع حاليًا بحوالي 80 إلى 90 بالمائة من التطعيم